so brains are composed of neurons and
synapses right those are the fundamental
units and computers are loosely speaking
constructive chips so let's just take
simply operating characteristics of
these smaller units neurons and chips
before we even get into higher level
systems differences like parallelism etc
what is the clock rate for a computer
you know that's how many gigahertz you
have right it's how many computations
can be performed per second
roughly on the order of say 10 to the
9th it's probably higher for some of the
faster computers and that just keeps
going up that's 10 to the 9th what's the
speed with which say neurons can compute
things well a neuron can only spike
that's the way information is
transmitted from one neuron to another
with an electrical signal sent down its
axon where it stimulates the dendrite of
the neighboring neuron I would say about
200 spikes per second would be really
high so you know let's say best-case
scenario 10 to the third is this clock
rate 10 to the third being about order
of you know one spike per millisecond
which is probably faster than we can we
can do so you have 10 to the ninth for
the computer 10 to the third for nerd
what about signal transmission how fast
does that signal move along the axon
well in computers electric signals
obviously travel the speed of light
which is if I recall correctly roughly
10 to the 8th meters per second how fast
do signals move along axons well roughly
10 to the second meters per second so 10
to the 9th 10 to the 3rd for clock rate
10 to the 8th 10 to the 2nd for signal
transmission speed what about noise
signal to noise ratio computers
basically the problem of noise is solved
if you run a program the same way you
always get the same answer right there's
very little noise in these circuits some
thermal noise it's estimated around 10
to the sixth which is 10 to the 6 signal
ratio to
always ratio in the neurons which hard
to estimate signal-to-noise ratio
because we don't even really know what
signal is but it's on the ballpark of
one you know charitably ten all right so
the noise is very very significant all
right so if you look at these just these
three operating characteristics and we
can discuss some of the systems level
differences as well you have ten to the
six that's the order of magnitude
difference between these operating
characteristics so then why is the
computer used as a metaphor and there's
a good reason why the computer is used
as a metaphor right I mean there have
been all kinds of metaphors about the
brain throughout history hydraulic
engines watches right Electrical
telephone signals right the prevailing
technology at the time and many articles
and books have been written about this
is generally the leading metaphor for
the brain because the brain obviously is
capable of the most remarkable functions
possible so I want to match that with
whatever technology is capable and this
takes back since the you know ancient
Greece which at the time of ancient
Greece basically these different
metaphors have evolved over time so now
we are able to get computers to do very
very remarkable things because we can do
remarkable things with computers because
we can do remarkable things with our
brains there's a natural tendency to say
brains and computers are alike they're
not okay how we're doing those things is
entirely different and then you mention
the other is parallelism right computers
do not work in parallel there's some
efforts at doing parallel processing
neuromorphic engineering none of those
that panned out
standard computers operate basically in
series and very rapidly okay so the
motif for computing in a computer is
lots of serial computations in the brain
you got the slow sloppy imprecise
computing but it's highly parallelized
and that's because each neuron in the
brain connects to 10 to the fourth other
neurons roughly 10,000 other neurons
that's a rule of thumb some are more and
some are less but the whole architecture
is different you maybe you've heard of
that game six ways to Kevin Bacon or six
connections you're Kevin Bacon degrees
six degrees of separation right Kevin
and so you start with one name and then
you make these associative jumps well
something like that actually existed the
brain it's called a small world
architecture and the idea is that no
synapse anywhere in the brain is more
than three or four synapses removed from
affecting some other synapse so these
are just Testaments to the degree to
which there's this parallel architecture
where everything is talking to
everything simultaneously but somehow
the system is organized in a way that
it's able to make sense it at all and
perform these remarkable functions okay
but this doesn't mean you're doing it
any way like the brain is doing it in
fact again the differences are striking
how did these object recognition
algorithms manage to all of a sudden
perform at this human level of
performance was it because there are
architectural changes the architectures
been the same since the early 80s is it
because they're any algorithmic changes
now my algorithm has been the same since
70s what's changed is processing speed
and the amount of data particularly part
of Moore's law processing speed doubling
what is it every two years or something
that has been maintained for a long time
this is what's going on we are good we
have developed the technology to enslave
electronic circuits for performing
trillions and trillions of calculations
in series to perform tasks amenable to
those operations and that's why object
recognition has been a problem where
we've made a lot of progress it's not
going to be the same for all the
problems as I said the problem of motor
control with Roger Federer for a variety
of reasons you have all these
interaction torques between all the
degrees of freedom of your body
it's a continuous
problem as opposed to a discrete
categorization problem
those are hard problems all right when
there's a computer or a robot that can
play tennis like Roger Federer then
we've solved those problems it's gonna
be a long time before we ever get to the
stage because it's just a different type
of intelligence okay
artificial intelligence will work better
for some emulating some types of natural
intelligence than others now you talked
about differences between the computers
in the brains let me give you another
strong one which also harkens to an area
where I do research as I was discussing
mnemonic techniques and so question is
how is information stored and processed
in the brain in the brain information is
stored in bits in these registers right
I have my one zero one zero one zero one
zero deuce to a binary code and I have
an address by which I can connect to
that register so if I want information
somewhere I need the address okay then I
go to the information so one point about
that information is that it's segregated
it's localized it's only there okay and
the address is what connects the user to
that information the brain is entirely
different okay all information is stored
relationally associational II in terms
of its content and it's all in a
distributed fashion meaning that
information is encoded in distributed
activation patterns that share neurons
for different pieces of information it's
not segregated in one register it's
spread everywhere okay and I don't have
someone reading it with an address it's
organized by content so in other words
you have this vast associative web
inside your head that's embodying
information about all your previous
experiences and knowledge and
information that you learn newly will
have to make sense and be referenced or
grounded by this associational web
that's how it enters it so
again this is just an entirely different
paradigm of how we learn right and how
we think then how a computer does it and
one way that you can see this is in the
use of mnemonic techniques to improve
people's memory I don't know how much
your audience is familiar with it lots
of people aren't familiar with it but
are these ancient techniques dating back
to Greece civilization gentleman named
Simone Eadie's and even actually further
back than that and if you apply these
techniques which I'll just describe very
cursorily
you can remember huge pieces of
information now why was this important
well in the old days papyrus was
expensive they didn't have computers
there was no printing press so you'd
want to learn vast pieces of information
you want to memorize your speeches etc
people practiced at this okay
and all of these techniques were based
on Association you would take some new
information and you'd relate it to some
old information and then you'd concoct
some kind of story up and voila the
magic of these techniques was that it
became really easy to remember lots of
things this is now a lost art we
completely ignore memory because we have
these electronic devices kids are not
even learning the multiplication tables
in school systems or kid writing or
handwriting right but think about what
an incredible mistake this could be if
these memory techniques embody a more
general associative computing faculty
that is being ignored in other words if
Association is a fundamental paradigm of
how we process information ie relating
new information to old information and
experience and putting it in context and
that helps us not only memorize things
but it helps us with pattern formation
concept formation even creativity
linking different things to each other
right it's all part of general neural
computing which we don't really
understand and if we all of a sudden
omit one major component of it memory
because the way memory
done in computers is so easy that we
have infinite amount of memory it would
be like not running on the treadmill not
staying in shape because I can drive a
car in a train to ever I want to go
right that one makes sense
you got to exercise the fundamental
faculties of your brain and if
association in memories only one
instantiation of it is an important
faculty and you're ignoring it that's a
problem but you only realize that if you
try to think carefully in a nuanced
fashion what are the differences between
how the brain works and how a computer
works and they are profound the
differences are far greater than
similarities only similarities is that
they're both capable of remarkable feats